Hi there,
this is my message to millennials about
how to change the world and I would say
how to change the world properly.
Of course,
the question then is,
well,
exactly what do you mean by properly?
And of course that's the fundamental
issue.
So I'm going to walk through that a
little bit.
So I'm gonna and I've also got an offer
to make to any millennials that are,
are willing to watch this.
So,
um,
this was triggered in part by something
I read recently by Jonathan Haidt and
Jonathan Haidt is the professor of
ethical leadership at a Nyu stern school
of business and he's been a very astute
commentator recently on some of the
political battles that have been going
on in the social sciences.
I'm noting,
for example,
that there is very little political
diversity in the views of social
scientists and perhaps even less on the
part of the people in the humanities.
Um,
and hate recently wrote something which
will all put a you linked to in the
description of this video where he
claimed that universities have to decide
between social justice and truth and on
the side of truth,
he puts a philosopher called named John
Stuart Mill and English philosopher who
said he who knows only his side of the
case knows little of that his reasons
may be good and no one may have been
able to refute them,
but if he is equally unable to refute
the reasons on the opposite side,
if he does not,
he does not so much as know what they
are.
He has no grown for preferring either
opinion.
And then he juxtaposes John Stuart mill
with Karl Marx who said,
the philosophers have only interpreted
the world in various ways.
The point is to change it.
He considers marks the patron saint of
social justice university,
which is oriented around changing the
world in part by overthrowing power
structures and privilege.
It sees political diversity as an
obstacle to action.
Male,
on the other hand,
according to hate,
is the patron saint of what he calls
truth.
You would,
she's truth as a process in which flawed
individuals challenging each other's
biased and incomplete reasoning and in
the process all become smarter,
hate points out the truth.
University dies when it becomes
intellectually uniform or politically
orthodox.
So I guess this video is in part my call
along with Jonathan Haidt for young
people to join truth university,
but there's a problem with that because
the university is where the truth is
being sought.
That's the university,
but there's a problem and that is that
young people want to change the world
and it's part of what piaget,
the developmental psychologists,
piaget called the messianic stage and
there's some real utility in that
because we're social creatures and,
um,
as we construct ourselves and,
and formulate ourselves and bring our
own character into being predicated on
our,
on our biological,
a platform,
our biological being.
We also simultaneously have to
integrate,
adjust to,
integrate with and negotiate with
society which sometimes needs to be
changed.
The structure of society has to be
preserved,
but it has to be updated and improved as
it moves forward.
And so part of the problem is how to
update and improve it without doing that
so rapidly that you destroy everything
of any value.
So the problem I have with the Marxist
perspective,
and I've had this problem with it for a
long time,
is that I don't think that you should
trust people whose primary goal,
when,
when they're attempting to change the
world for the better is to change other
people.
And you can tell who those people are
because they're always blaming other
people and they're looking for victims.
They're looking for perpetrators and
victims.
And then they're going off to stop the
perpetrators.
And I think that's wrong because as
Aleksandr Solzhenitsyn said,
he's a great Russian writer who helped
bring down the Soviet Union.
He said the line between good and evil
runs down every,
every human's heart.
So,
so the real battle as far as I'm
concerned,
and I think this goes along with the
tradition in which John Stuart mill is
firmly placed and is that to overcome
tyranny and malevolence and chaos and
nihilism,
and the desire to bring everything to a
halt.
You have to repair the fissures.
And the and the riff that's in your own
soul basically,
and that means that you have to confront
the evil that lives in your own heart.
And there's a,
there's a statement from the New
Testament that I think is very much
apropos with regards to this particular
idea.
And this is a car.
There's this part of the sermon on the
mount,
which is a central text in,
in Western,
in the western tradition,
I would say obviously central to
Christianity,
but central to everything that Western
civilization has built.
And so Christ says to his followers,
um,
why behold thou the moat that is in your
brother's eye,
but consider it's not the beam that is
in [inaudible] or how will they'll say
to thy brother,
let me pull out the mote out of Sinai.
And behold,
a beam is in Dine Oni.
Thou hypocrite first cast out the beam
out of the nine Onei.
And then shalt thou see clearly to cast
out of thy brother's eye.
While I like that quote,
because it places the responsibility for
change at every level of being on the
individual.
And obviously the individual interacts
with society.
But the idea here is that unless the
individual straightens out his or her
own soul,
there is no possibility that the impact
the individual can have on society can
be anything,
but let's say harmful in proportion to
the harm that's still in the soul.
These are important things to know.
There are vitally important things to
know.
So okay,
so.
But then we're faced with a conundrum
that young people also want to change
the world.
But that's no problem because I think
you can bring.
You can bring truth university together
with a desire to,
to make real change,
but change,
change,
change has to start in the right place.
So I'm going to tell you how I think you
should change yourself so that you can
change the world.
And so the,
the world that you bring into being will
be a better world in order.
Worst one,
remember,
you need to know about this,
that the world that the followers of
mark's brought into being in the 20th
century killed more than 100 million
people say in China and Russia,
the Soviet Union,
and in places like Cambodia and Vietnam,
the world certainly changed as a
consequence Marxist doctrine,
but it didn't change in in a good
direction.
And of course the Marxist doctrine is,
is making itself heard in a massive way
across the west again.
Now.
So.
All right,
so what should you do about that?
Well,
here,
here's an idea.
The first thing you have to do is Orient
Yourself.
Now you probably have all watched
Pinocchio.
Pinocchio was about how a Marionette,
someone whose whose strings are being
pulled by forces beyond his
comprehension.
That's the situation of the undeveloped
individual Japan Eto,
who's a benevolent father,
so benevolent,
a symbol,
a symbol of benevolent culture,
makes a puppet his son,
and then wishes on a star.
Now,
a star is something that glitters up in
the sky and it's,
and it's,
it's associated with the transcendent
and the beyond and the divine.
And you know,
if you look up in the night sky and it's
very dark,
you get a feeling of arts because you're
confronting your soul,
so to speak.
Your individual soul is confronting the
cosmos and you can feel the relationship
between you and and and,
and the totality.
So looking up into the sky as a like a
religious experience,
if it's a starry sky,
and to wish upon a star is to find in a
light that orients you like the North
Star,
and to pick a highest goal,
to pick the highest school you can
conceive of.
And so that's what Japan does.
He raises his eyes above his,
his day to day concerns and tries to
establish a relationship with the
highest of all possible values.
And,
and,
and he has the most profound of wishes.
And the most profound of wishes is that
the puppet that he's created could
become a genuine individual,
genuinely,
fully,
fully developed human being.
And that's what you can wish for
yourself.
That you can wish and,
and,
and aim for that in yourself.
And then you see,
that's how you deal with the suffering.
That's attendant on life because life is
suffering and because life is very hard
and people get sick and they they become
mentally ill and and and there's
malevolence in the world and there's
tragedy and so life is very,
very hard and if you're not properly
oriented with regards to life,
the fact that it's hard and the fact
that it's full of suffering can,
can warp and twist and bend you until
you become murderous and resentful and,
and even go beyond murders and
resentment to wish for,
for genocide and evil,
even to wish for the destruction of
everything.
And so you have to learn how to
strengthen yourself as an individual so
that you can bear the burden of being
without becoming corrupt.
You have to decide that that is what
you're aiming for,
is that you want to become a fully
developed human being and start being a
pathetic marionette whose strings are
being pulled by horrible forces behind
the scenes.
So I would say to any to wish on a star
is to aim at the highest good.
And the question then is,
well,
what?
What is the good?
Well,
we can answer that in two ways.
We could say that the good is the
opposite of evil and I can tell you what
evil is.
Evil is the conscious desire to produce
suffering were suffering is not
necessary and so if you read about what
happened in the Nazi concentration
camps,
for example,
or in the in the Russian concentration
camps during the Soviet time of the
Soviet Union,
you get a good flavor for what
constitutes evil and evil is the desire
to exploit the vulnerability of other
people,
to self consciously exploit the
vulnerability of other people and to
elevate their suffering beyond there or
anyone's ability to tolerate and so the
good is the opposite of that.
Whatever the opposite of that is the
good is harder to get a handle on.
But here's one hint,
and I got this from reading.
John Piaget,
partly who's a developmental
psychologist and Piaget talked about the
elevated state and then the state is
like a game that children play where
every child wants to play the game.
You have a little social group and
that's the children's playgroup and any
of the individuals within it.
Those are the individual children and
the and the structure is the game and
it's a good game if everyone wants to
play it.
And and Piaget noted that a game like
that will outperform a game that people
have to be tyrannized to play because it
doesn't entail.
It doesn't require any enforcement cost.
And so I've,
I've sort of developed the idea of Neil
equilibrated state to think that if,
if you're aiming at the good then you
want what's good for you and I mean good
for you as if you were taking care of
yourself and we're good to yourself who
were treating yourself like someone you
loved,
that it was good for you in a way that
would also be good for your family and
then it would be good for you and your
family in a way that was also good for
society.
And then it would be good for you and
your family and society in a way that
would be good for the world.
And then it would be good now and it
would be good next week and the week
after,
and a year from now and as long into the
future as you can see.
So the good is something that's
equivalent rated across multiple levels
of being in multiple timeframes
simultaneously and it isn't necessarily
that you know what that is going to be
at any given moment,
but you can orient yourself so that's
the state that you want to exist in.
And I can tell you as far as I can tell,
when you exist in that state,
even moment by moment,
your life is imbued with a sense of
meaning and that sense of meaning can
help you transcend suffering.
The philosopher Nietzsche said,
he who has a why can bear anyhow,
he who has a why can bear anyhow and so
niches.
Idea was that if there was purpose in
your life,
have sufficient grandier that not only
could the suffering in life be accepted,
but maybe could even be appreciated.
Like it could be that you're willing to
bear the burden of being because of the
exciting things that you can do with
being the things you can build in,
the things that you can bring about and
that might be the highest imaginable
state of being and that's that's a form
of paradise,
but it's not a paradise that you
attained by transforming others.
It's a paradise that you attain by
transforming yourself and that's a very
difficult thing to do and it's a very
frightening thing to do because it means
that you're.
You're retooling your soul and that's.
That's a job for a real.
That's the job for a forthright and
honorable person and it's an exciting
enough task so that it will keep you
occupied for the rest of your life and
then magical things will happen to you
while you're.
While you're doing it and the world will
itself around you in the most wonderful
way,
in a musical way.
So that every part of what you're
experiencing plays off against every
other part in a manner that's has
meaning embedded in every aspect of it.
And you experienced that by the way you
experienced that.
When you listen to a piece of music that
you love,
music represents that,
and that's why people.
That's why Mira music nourishes the
soul.
Why?
It's the highest form of art,
at least in my opinion.
So you have to live your life as if
being is as symphony and you're playing,
you're playing your instrumental part.
Once you Orient Yourself,
then you have an obligation,
I would say an obligation to the
development of your soul,
to speak the truth.
You have to be oriented properly.
They'll because the truth is,
is something that exists in service to
an ideal,
an ideal of sorts.
Then you can imagine that you could use
your language two ways.
You can use your language to manipulate
the world and to extract from it what
you want.
So for example,
maybe you go out into date with someone
and you decide that the end goal of the
date is to have a sexual partner for the
night.
And then you can craft your language to
manipulate the person into providing you
with you with what you want.
And that's like an instrumental use of
language,
but the problem with that,
there's many problems with that,
but one of them is,
is that what if your idea about what you
should want is wrong,
like maybe that's not the way to treat
someone that you're on a date out on a
date with maybe.
Maybe you're minimizing and reducing the
interactions between you from what could
be a healthy and elevated state of
interaction and discourse to something
that's that basically the pursuit of
impulsive pleasure and not maybe that's
not good for you.
Next week and the week after a month
down the road,
maybe orienting yourself towards
impulsive pleasure is a very bad idea.
Remember what happens in Pinocchio.
Pinocchio goes to Pleasure Island and
pleasure island is a place where
impulsive pleasures can be had at at a
moment's notice,
but what Pinocchio discovers along with
Jimminy Cricket,
that pleasure island is run by masked
totalitarians.
There.
They're all dressed in black.
You remember?
They're,
they're turning the children and
adolescents who are on pleasure island.
They're depriving them of their voice,
turning them into bring jackasses and
preparing to sell them as slaves to the
salt mines,
and so there's an implication in that
story that the pursuit of impulsive
pleasure is one route to totalitarianism
and slavery,
and I believe that so perhaps orienting
your language towards the gathering of
the impulsive pleasure is a miss,
is a misuse of your highest gift.
The gift of logos,
that gift of communication.
The alternative is to Orient Yourself
towards the highest good as we already
described it,
and then the truth which and you can.
You can tell when you're doing that
because you can tell her when you're not
doing that because if you're.
If you're not telling the truth,
if you're using someone else's words,
you're being manipulated in a sense by
forces that are behind the scenes.
You're not using your own words.
You're the puppet of an ideology or
another thinker or your own impulsive
desires and you can tell when you're
speaking like that because it makes you
feel weak.
It makes you feel weak and ashamed and
you can localize that feeling
physiologically.
If you listen to yourself talk,
you can tell when when you're speaking
properly,
you will experience a feeling of
integration and strength and when you're
speaking in a deceitful or manipulative
manner,
you'll feel that you're starting to come
across apart at the seams and what you
need to do is practice only saying
things that make you feel stronger and
that'll mean to begin with.
You'll notice that almost everything you
say is a lie.
It's either a lie or someone else's
words.
It's very hard to find your own words,
but you don't actually exist until you
have your own words,
so okay,
so then you.
You try to teach yourself how to speak
your own truth and you listen to other
people while you're doing that because
they can help you shape and correct your
words.
They'll react to them badly if you
formulate your ideas badly,
and if you listen and pay attention,
then you can learn to formulate your
words more and more clearly and
accurately,
and that makes you more and more
powerful.
It makes you.
It gives you more and more authority,
which is the which is the beneficial
form of power.
Okay,
so you do that and then you have to make
a decision of faith and that's basically
where you can easily either use your
language to manipulate the world and
make it do what you want or you can use
your language to try to articulate the
truth as carefully as you possibly can,
and then you can see what happens.
You have to let go of your desire for
the for the consequences that you want.
You have to assume that if you speak the
truth,
the results are the best that is
possible under the circumstances and so
it's a.
it's an exciting way of living in
simpsons.
Some sense it's like continually walking
off a cliff because you don't know
what's going to happen next.
If all you do is say what you think,
you know,
and maybe you're at work and you say
what you think and you get fired and you
think,
oh my God,
that's a terrible catastrophe,
but maybe it's not.
Because maybe if you're working
somewhere and you have to lie to
maintain your job,
maybe you shouldn't be there.
Maybe it's deadening your soul and
damaging you in some permanent manner
and making you corrupt and so you have
to Orient Yourself.
You have to speak the truth as carefully
as you can,
and you have to listen to others so that
you correct your speech and then you
have to allow the consequences that
ensue to unfold as they will.
That's the ultimate act of faith,
I would say,
and that's what you do.
If you belong to truth university.
All right,
so more practically speaking,
then you should educate yourself and
it's not that easy to do now because you
have to find people who can actually
tell you mostly what to read and maybe
also how to write because writing is a
way of formulating your thoughts
evermore precisely.
That's why you go to university to learn
how to write.
If you learn,
if you know how to write,
you can think.
If you can think and speak and
communicate in writing,
you're unbelievably powerful in the
authority manner because arguments move
the world forward and if your arguments
are tight and well constructed and lucid
and well edited and carefully thought
through and you have five rationales for
everything that you're doing,
which is what happens if you learn to
write properly,
then you're like a force of nature,
man.
No one can take you down and that's one
of the things that people aren't taught
about.
Why you go get educated,
especially in the humanities,
humanities education,
if it's real,
organizes your psyche grounds.
You puts you on a rock and makes you a
force to contend with,
but you have to read the right people
and so and those are the great,
the great people of the past in my list.
They're the great men of the past and
that's just how it is,
and so here's who I would recommend.
I put reading lists up at Jordan B
Peterson Dotcom.
There's two of them and the people that
I recommend primarily are there books
written by the following list of people,
Theodore,
Dostoevsky and Tolstoy,
who I think perhaps the greatest
novelist the world has ever seen.
Alexander Solzhenitsyn,
another great Russian novelist.
I don't know what it is about the
Russians,
but man,
they produce.
They produce.
Writers that are in comparable.
Alexander Solzhenitsyn wrote a book
called the Gulag archipelago where he
analyzed the Soviet prison camp system
that arose after the leninist revolution
in the second decade of the 20th century
and details and absolutely precisely how
the tenants of Marxism,
Marxists tenants that are supposed to
free everyone and changed the world
produced legislation that was,
that was absolutely murderous in its
consequences and social units and
painstakingly traces the logical pathway
from the original Marxist principles to
the legislation to the to the genocides.
Because you'll hear people who are
basically Marxist to say things like,
well,
true Marxism never existed and social
units.
And took that.
That argument apart in the in the mid
seventies and and the gulag.
Archipelago was an intellectual bomb.
It,
it,
it demolished any credibility that
Marxism had to intellectual
respectability.
You have to read the book.
The book is about the central issue in
our culture at the moment.
If you don't read it,
you're not informed.
You can't participate in the debate
except as a puppet.
And so I wouldn't recommend
participating in this debate as a puppet
because you don't know who's behind the
scenes pulling the strings.
If you remember the Pinocchio Story,
the forces that were pulling the strings
were not,
uh,
they were not forces that we're acting
in Pinocchio's best interest,
that's for sure.
George Orwell,
English essayist in comparable
commentator on socialist
totalitarianism,
even though he was a left winger and a
brilliant one.
Aldous Huxley wrote Brave New World,
uh,
had some very brilliant things to say
about the potential demolition of sexual
choice,
of choice of sexual partner as a part of
part of a dystopian future.
Friedrich Nietzsche,
the philosopher who described himself
as,
as someone who thought with a hammer and
Nietzsche is a very,
very dangerous person and an absolutely
brilliant writer.
And Carl Young,
who was a student of Nisha and who Nisha
was the philosopher who I announced the
death of God back in the late 18
hundreds and spent his whole life
attempting to revivify God.
That's one way of thinking about it.
And so if you educate yourself,
and this is a really good place to
start.
If you read these authors,
then you'll know what else to read.
it'll,
it'll take you a good long time and it
will be very,
very hard on you and,
and you won't be the same person when
you come out.
And that's very frightening.
And because being torn down and rebuilt
is no is no joke,
but it beats the hell out of the
alternative,
which is just to stagnate and stay as
stagnant infant,
which is,
which is not something I'd recommend.
There's nothing uglier than a stagnant
40 year old infant.
So that's equivalent.
Just so you know,
to Pinocchio,
Back to the Pinocchio Story,
rescuing Japan from the underworld.
Remember when he was,
he had kind of turned into a half
jackass after being at the at pleasure
island,
where he was enticed by the way from a
couple of people who that was the Fox
and the cat who attempted to entice
himself into believing that he was a
victim and needed a vacation.
So Pinocchio was enticed onto pleasure
island by two,
two fingers that that played on his
sense of victimization and neurosis and
suffering to convince him that he didn't
have to.
He didn't have to take any
responsibility for his own existence and
he could just be busy himself with
impulsive pleasures.
Right?
That's how we fell into the hands of the
totalitarians on pleasure island.
Um,
anyways,
Pinocchio,
after he left,
pleasure island had to go into the ocean
twice.
And the second time he went into the
ocean,
he was looking for his father.
Well,
everyone's father from a mythological
perspective,
is dying in the underworld,
in the chaos because everyone inhabits a
culture that's sick and old,
so to speak.
And it's sick and old because it was
made by the dad and the living have to
revivify it continually in order for it
to be a dynamic force and the living
have to revive a fi,
their connection with the culture
internally too,
because your constructions of culture,
although not only constructions of
culture and you have to understand
history because otherwise you can't
understand yourself.
You're a historical creature and so you
have to rescue your dead father from the
belly of the beast,
from the Dragon Guess Remember the whale
in Pinocchio is also a fire breathing
dragon.
And that means you have to face the
thing that you most fear.
And when you do that,
you'll rescue your father from the
underworld.
These are very complex ideas and you can
read about them in my book.
Maps of meaning if you want.
It's on the reading list.
I put a free copy of it on Jordan would
be Peterson Dotcom.
So you can download it.
I take apart these sorts of things in
detail.
So anyways,
you have to vivify your father before
you can become real.
And,
and that's part of the problem with the
feminist and feminist and social justice
warrior insistence on the existence of
the patriarchy.
It's like everyone's known since the
beginning of time,
that culture is corrupt and tyrannical,
but it's also protective and benevolent.
Even the language use is a product of
culture,
and so you don't overthrow the
patriarchy,
you a fire your culture,
and you do that by adopting
responsibility for your own being and
then acting as a moral agent in the
culture.
That's what you do to become educated.
So read these books,
read these books.
They'll change your life.
I guarantee it.
They'll take you apart,
they'll devastate you,
and then they'll rebuild you into
something far greater than you are now.
But don't worry,
Jenny,
you need to get yourself out.
Follow the chamber and you'll find
wrong.
You will bring in folks,
I just wasn't quick enough.
Phoenix tears have healing powers
and that's what to aim for.
So then,
and here's something that will help you.
My colleagues and I have developed a
series of online writing programs called
the cell phone ring suite,
and they help people write about their
past and organize that and they're
present personality and organize and
understand that and then the future and
the future authoring program asks you to
write about six different dimensions of
your life so it asked you first of all,
treat yourself as if you're someone that
you want to help and that someone that
you love and take care of it and someone
that you want to help and then it asked
you.
Well,
if you could,
if you could organize your life in the
best possible manner and in keeping with
those principles we discussed earlier,
what do you want?
What do you want for your career?
Like what do you want?
What would make your life meaningful?
What do you want for your career?
What do you want for your family and
from your family?
What do you want for an intimate
relationship?
How are you going to handle?
How are you going to take care of your
mental and physical health?
How are you going to handle drug,
drug and alcohol use?
It asks you a series of fundamental
questions like that to get your mind
moving and then it asks you to write for
15 minutes about what your life could be
like 53 to five years in the future if
it was laid out like you were laying out
a life for someone you deeply cared
about and so you're asked to write for
15 minutes about that without worrying
too much about structure,
the structure of the argument or or or
any grammatical niceties that that's put
off for later.
So that gives you a little heaven name
for it,
right?
It's like,
well,
if I could have this,
my life would be clearly worthwhile.
Even if I had to put up with a fair bit
of suffering along the way.
That's what you're trying to construct
and you could think about that as a
heaven worth moving towards.
And then the second part of the program
asked to write about what your life
would be like three to five years down
the road.
If all of your bad habits and nihilistic
tendencies and proclivity towards
resentment and lack of desire to
shoulder responsibility,
fall your weak points,
got the upper hand and just augured you
into the ground and everyone knows that
you know what you'd be like.
If you just let everything slide and and
you know what particular hell you were
ended up heading towards and so the sec,
the second part of the program asked you
to write about what your life would be
like three to five years down the road
if everything just went to hell around
you and so that gives you a hell to
avoid and heaven to strive for and you
need both of those because that's what
keeps you properly motivated in life.
And then the second half of the program
that the next part of the program helps
you turn your vision of the desirable
future into an implementable reality and
to articulate it fully and to articulate
the arguments for why you want that and
those even help you overcome your own
doubts.
Right?
It's not only to argue against other
people,
it's to argue against the chattering
demons of nihilism and hopelessness and
the ideological possession that that
exist in your mind and in society
simultaneously.
You need powerful weapons to fight back
against those.
So here's an offer for you.
We've made the future authoring program
available free for the next while.
I'm,
I don't know how long a while be,
but let's assume a week or something
like that.
And so if you go to ww dot [inaudible]
dot com slash future authoring dot html,
you can read about the program there and
now I got to tell you,
we've used this program and about 5,000
university students so far,
mostly in Holland but some in Canada as
well.
And what we've shown is that they,
the program,
if you complete this program,
even if you do it badly and I would
recommend it,
do it badly,
man,
it doesn't matter.
You don't have to do it perfectly.
Do it badly,
and then maybe do it better as you move
forward,
but at least do it badly.
It increases the performance of
university students.
It increases their grades by between 20
and 25 percent and decreases their
dropout by about the same percent,
and so we have data on 5,000 people.
One of those papers is been published
and I'll put that in the,
in the description,
in the description of this video,
and so this program really works if you
do it and and so I would highly
recommend that you do it anyways.
You can read about the program there.
Click purchase for $14,
95.
Then enter this code,
change yourself,
that'll give you a 1495 discount and
that means you can have the program for
free.
And so here's what millennials should
do.
If they want to change the world,
the first thing they should do is orient
themselves to the good and that's away
from evil,
away from malevolence,
away from the manufacturer of pointless
suffering and pain away from Auschwitz,
let's say in a way from the Gulag
archipelago and the terrible Soviet
camps and the massive murders that
occurred in China.
You want to get it and you want to get
as far away from that as you possibly
can.
Whatever direction is away from that is
a good direction,
and then you also wanted to contemplate
what the highest possible good could
look like for you and your family and
your society.
We already discussed that and then you
need to speak the truth in relationship
to that,
and then you need to educate yourself
and then you need to shoulder you're
responsibility.
Responsibility is a good thing because
it makes you strong to bear up under.
It makes you strong.
You can turn yourself into a.
You can free yourself from your strings
and turn yourself into a genuine
individual and then you can shoulder the
world and then you're in a position to
make to make change.
As a person like that,
your mirror being will change the world
in a positive direction and that's what
you should be aiming for.
So read the books that I put up on my
site and do the future authoring program
and that will improve your life
dramatically and that's how you can
change the world.